as the water level at lake mead declines  there's a new way some are measuring it  this vertical speed boat we first showed  you this video last month showing the  boat that is was in relatively deep  water at some point  several feet from shore that was three  weeks ago now take a look at this  here is what it looks like now  in the newest picture since then the  lake has dropped more than four feet  as of this past weekend the boat is  still upright  but practically on dry land  past trends show the decreasing water  levels will slow down in july and could  even increase slightly through august  and september with some water releases  we'll see what happens oh my gosh that  is a crazy crazy photo well we certainly  could